pensé que sería muy interesante que
tengamos más intuición para el tema de
las elipses y sus focos así que vamos a
trabajar en ello tenemos este ejercicio
interactivo en khan academy así que
veamos cómo jugar con él para que
aprendamos todos juntos sobre las
elipses muy bien y nos dice la ecuación
de la elipse es x menos x en el cuadrado
dividido entre a cuadrada más o menos de
1 al cuadrado dividido entre b cuadrada
igual a 1 verdad y este es justamente la
ecuación de una elipse donde esta
ecuación nos da mucha información verdad
nos dice que el centro se encuentra en
el digamos tiene coordenada x igual a x1
y su coordenada vale y 1 mientras que la
longitud digamos de los semi ejes es a y
verdad dependiendo de cuál sea más
grande es lo que nos dice si la elipse
está digamos acomodada de forma
horizontal o de forma vertical muy bien
ahora nos dice el ejercicio encuentra
los focos de la elipse siguiente de la
elipse siguiente
tenemos aquí abajo moviendo los puntos
anaranjados a sus posiciones correctas
muy bien después usa esa información
para encontrar los valores de x 1 y 1
que es lo que nos da el centro ahí ve
que es la longitud de los semiejes
verdad y aquí nos da las cajitas para
que podamos acomodar esos números y en
este momento nos dice en qué coordenadas
se encuentran los focos verdad estos
puntos naranja que nosotros podemos ir
moviendo muy bien entonces nosotros
sabemos que para que los focos estén
bien localizados lo que debe pasar es
que la suma de estas distancias debe ser
constante verdad por ejemplo está esta
longitud esta longitud verde y la
longitud rosa están indicadas arriba en
donde dice distancia al foco 1 y
distancia al foco 2 verdad es lo que
aparece de este lado cuando me encuentro
cerca de la elipse el punto es que
cuando nos vamos moviendo alrededor de
la elipse la suma de las distancias no
es constante eso quiere decir que esos
puntos
activamente no son los focos ok entonces
esto es definitivamente no son los focos
así que uno podría estar explorando
moviendo los puntos a lo largo de todo
el interior de este elipse y tratar de
encontrar en qué momento si es si son
los focos verdad sin embargo a mí se me
hace un poco complicado estar buscando
en todos los puntos posibles de este
elipse así que sería mejor o al menos a
mí se me hace mucho más sencillo hallar
el centro de la elipse primero que eso
lo podemos hacer inspeccionando la
imagen verdad y luego vamos a tratar de
hallar los valores de las longitudes de
los semiejes muy bien entonces vamos a
ver cómo podríamos encontrar el centro
de esta elipse bueno más o menos se ve
que aquí está uno de los vértices y acá
está otro entonces debe estar como a la
mitad de esos dos puntos más o menos yo
pensaría que ese es el centro vamos a
confirmarlo la distancia de este punto a
este extremo de la elipse
nos dice que es día es verdad aquí nos
va a parecer que es 10 mientras que la
distancia al otro lado también es 10
entonces justo está a la mitad de esta
de este segmento verdad mientras que si
nos fijamos en la parte vertical nos
dice que la distancia digamos la
distancia de vertical a la elipse es 8
mientras que si nos vamos hacia abajo
nos dice que también es 8 entonces este
es justamente el centro de nuestra
elipse y que justamente podemos ver que
tiene coordenada x igual a menos 6
estamos entre menos 8 y menos 4 es menos
6 vamos a escribirlo aquí
esto es -6 y tiene coordenada y pues
bajamos hasta -8 verdad estamos en menos
en coordenada menos 8 muy bien ahora
vamos a ver cuál es la longitud del
semieje y que eso está dado del semi eje
horizontal y que se está dado por a
bueno pues es justamente la distancia a
este punto verdad que es que es nuestro
intento de foco que en realidad sabemos
que es el centro y nos dice que es 10 a
vale 10 mientras que b nos indica que es
justamente 88 verdad entonces aquí
tenemos que el semieje mayor es 10 y el
semilla que menor es 8 y nosotros
sabemos muy bien cómo encontrar los
focos a partir de una fórmula que vimos
en uno de los vídeos anteriores verdad
nos dice que el valor sé que es la
distancia del centro al foco verdad a
cualquiera de los focos es cuadrada
menos b cuadrada y sacar la raíz
cuadrada verdad o lo que es lo mismo al
cuadrado menos
de cuadrada nos da el valor de s
cuadrada donde se es la distancia del
centro al foco verdad y para obtener el
valor de s simplemente hay que sacar la
raíz cuadrada entonces tenemos 10 al
cuadrado es 100 y si le restamos 8 al
cuadrado serían 64 y 100 menos 64 son 36
verdad entonces sí a 100 le restamos 64
nos da 36 y si sacamos raíz cuadrada de
6 verdad entonces la distancia de este
punto a los focos debe ser 6 verdad
entonces movemos 1 y sería 1 2 3 4 5 6 y
de ahora de aquí es 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 esta
es nuestra propuesta de donde están los
focos y vamos a verificarlo la distancia
la suma de las distancias es constante y
de hecho la constante es exactamente 20
y no importa por donde nos estemos
moviendo a lo largo d
la elipse verdad entonces podemos ver
que la ecuación de esta elipse sería x
menos x1 que en este caso es menos 6
sería x 6 al cuadrado dividido entre 100
que es cuadrada más y en menos de 1 que
sería de más 8 al cuadrado dividido
entre de cuadrada que sería 64 nos debe
dar 1 y eso nos da esta elipse verdad
entonces podemos ver que la suma de las
distancias es constante y es justamente
lo que define a una elipse verdad si
quisiéramos dibujarla por ejemplo en un
pizarrón podríamos poner una cuerda que
está fijada a estos dos puntos verdad
que serían los focos podemos poner no sé
a lo mejor una agujeta si estás en tu
salón de clases ponemos el heat no ok
digamos en medio de sagú que está y
vamos trazando lo con esos dos extremos
fijos en los focos bueno como sea espero
que te hayas divertido en este vídeo
tanto como yo lo hice